Iran has conducted combat operations
beyond its borders with conventional, as
well as advisory forces, in Iraq and
Syria since 2015. We've observed this
development by tracking Iranian troop
rotations in Farsi and Arabic media, and
on social media. Iran used to rely on
proxies is guided by the clandestine Quds
Force. It hasn't sent the conventional
Islamic Revolutionary Guards Corps
beyond its borders since the nineteen
eighties. Its regular military, the Artesh,
has never fought abroad.
That's changed. Parts of IRGC brigades
have fought in Syria alongside Hezbollah
and Iraqi militias. Artesh units are
fighting in Syria. Even the internal-
security-come-morality-police-
organization, called the Basij, has sent
combat units to Syria. Iran is creating
the ability to lead and fight with a
coalition of tens of thousands of
proxy forces, hundreds of miles from
its borders, for the first time in its
history, and its asking Russia to sell it
advanced aircraft, tanks, and anti-shipping
missiles that would give it one of the
region's most powerful militaries. The US must
take determined – but not hasty – action to
address this new challenge from an old adversary.
If you liked this video, check
out CriticalThreats.org for more
coverage on the challenges facing the
United States abroad. We track threats
from al-Qaeda to Iran. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like AEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds.